cela ressemble à un feuilleton un peu
trop long un épisode sans fin qui
commence à lasser des deux côtés de la
manche
réunis la semaine dernière à bruxelles
les négociateurs britanniques et
européens n'ont pas pu trouver d'accord
cette septième session de discussions
c'est donc de nouveau avérées
infructueuses les deux camps se
rejettent la faute
concernant ce blocage et c'est désormais
le pessimisme qui règne pour michel
barnier le représentant de l'union
européenne ne cache pas sa déception
tout empreint de l'esprit trop souvent
cette semaine nous avons eu l'impression
de reculer plus que d'avancer étant
donné le peu de temps qu'il nous reste
ce que j'ai dit à londres en janvier
reste vraie bataille chez green in town
in july women choo today aujourd'hui à
ce stade un accord entre le royaume uni
et l'union européenne semblent peu
probables unlikely h et je ne comprend
tout simplement pas pourquoi nous
perdons un temps précieux et si son
homologue britannique david frost a
réaffirmé qu'un accord était l'objectif
de londres force est de constater qu'au
rythme où vont les choses le scénario
d'une ode il se rapproche à grands pas
concrètement les points de blocage
concerne la future relation commerciale
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne bruxelles souhaiterait que
londres continue de se plier à un
certain nombre de règles en vigueur sur
le vieux continent tandis que les
britanniques souhaitent justement
pouvoir s'acquitter de normes et de
contraintes
craignant de voir se développer une
forme de concurrence à ses portes
l'union européenne veut des garanties
avant de conclure des accords
commerciaux avec le royaume uni
l'autre grand sujet de discorde et celui
de la pêche puisque les pêcheurs
européens sont nombreux à travailler
dans les eaux britanniques un sujet
primordial pour les 27 mai dont londres
ne semble pas faire une priorité
ces trois jours de discussions n'auront
donc abouti à rien et côté français on
sent poindre une forme de lassitude
un tweet du secrétaire d'état chargé des
affaires européennes insiste sur
l'intransigeance du couple
franco-allemand message diffusé peu
après la visite d'angela merkel au fort
de brégançon pour y rencontrer emmanuel
macron et si chacun campe sur ses
positions alors on se dirige tout droit
r1 odile ce qui signifie que ce sont les
règles de l'om sait qui s'appliquerait
conséquence des frais de douane élevés
et des contrôles douaniers rétabli aux
frontières un scénario loin d'être
idéales pour des économies déjà bien
affecté par la crise sanitaire
il ne reste plus que quelques semaines
pour parvenir à un accord et sauver ce
qui peut l'être dans ce divorce
particulièrement longs entre le royaume
uni et l'union européenne